the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to talk about few
spoilers that the showrunners David
Benioff and Danny always along with two
main actresses sophie Turner actors the
place and sign Maine civilians and
actors displays Aria revealed and
confirmed that the annual conglomerate
of film interactive media and
conferences at South by Southwest let's
start with me this reply on a question
about why Sophie still has a blonde hair
instead of fake Holborn Maisie
surprisingly replied that she is that
we're from the panel went awkwardly
silent only to a moment later one of the
showrunners David Benioff gave an
extension on Maine's its reply Benioff
sad don't worry they won't tell anyone
which resulted it's uncomfortable laugh
from the audience now you're probably
wondering this spoiler did they just
reveal senseless death in the upcoming
season before I give you my opinion on
that let's just mention a few Sophie's
interviews that she had throughout last
few months in recent interviews sophie
has stated that she's sad about Game of
Thrones coming to an end
gave us a hint that she might die in
season seven with her statement that
there is one more season to film
pointing on the final season and sadly
added but not for all of us beside all
still more than confusing replies there
are also few behind-the-scenes photos
that revealed sense as absence from a
few major cast gatherings that have
shown Sofie for the first time bearing
an Auburn vague instead of dyeing her
hair as she had been doing all of these
years
sophie wearing a vague was more than
enough for a huge amount of people to
start making a serious about sense of
death in season seven pointing that
sophie bearing of vegas implying that
she didn't bother to dye her hair
because their limited sense has seen
since season seven pointing that sense i
won't survive the upcoming season
pointing that she's going to die in the
first few episodes in my opinion Sansa
Stark won't die anytime soon
not to mention in the following season
there are a few simple reasons that
let's hope we turn to use a vague
instead of dying curve here which is
because her hair suffered a lot from
dying after all of these years and
because she had been shooting scenes for
season seven at the same time she could
be working on a new movie that requires
her natural hair color along with a
lot of fake tattoos so yeah not only
that in my opinion sense of won't die
anytime soon but she along with your
sister Aria will avenge their family
I've already brought you a theory in
which Littlefinger is going to die on
his first wedding night after he marry
Sansa Stark the wedding at once and as
little thing once the wedding that is
going to be orchestrated by stark
sisters by Arya and Sansa so feel free
to check it out for all details if you
haven't already let's continue with
showrunners confirmation about the final
eight season showrunners by revealing
the writing assignments for season eight
have also revealed that the last sees
the mill contain only six episodes which
means that in two upcoming seasons
they're going to enjoy only thirteen
episodes at season seven we'll have
seven episodes bending of advice
revealed at the first episode of the
final season will be written by Dave
hill the second episode by Bryan cogman
and remaining four episodes by
themselves combined one of the most
interesting replies the showrunners gave
themselves was reply to Benny of
answering a question about whether or
not jon snow in Daenerys will meet each
other
Benny said that feels so obvious maybe
we should just avoid that
it seems that Ben you didn't see more
than a few leaked photos of kids
Harrington known as Jon Snow and Emilia
Clarke known as Daenerys being together
a shooting set a lot of Lee photos that
were taken on filming set on islet of
the Stalag acts in Basque Country
location which will represent
Dragonstone in the upcoming season
besides a photo that was taken from a
distance which is without a doubt the
first and official meeting between
Daenerys Targaryen and jumps now there
are much more photos from the filming
set that included both of those main
characters these photos that I've
already explained in a video about fate
of Jon Snow in season 7 among surely
interesting but for us not that
important topics that they were talking
about yesterday at South by Southwest
such as choosing their favorites debts
choosing their best sprang that David
and then have pulled out there's also
been a us reply on a possibility of
having get someone sad a dragon white
Walker at some point of Game of Thrones
Benyus reply was maybe with an i from
recent teaser that looks more like an
eye of dragon then of a white Walker
with Lakes blood that announced that of
one of Benny's dragons same link plot
that matches it a lot of leaked photos
and it
of supply there's a huge possibility
that one of the nurses dragons says
loquats says will they kill then
reanimated by the night king the last
let's call it spoiler that I would like
to highlight is Ed Sheeran's appearance
in season seven who was as Benioff set
himself invited as a surprise for Maisy
those are in my opinion the most notable
spoilers or Kane's
that these four revealed yesterday and
as always let me know your thoughts
about all of this in the comment section
down below hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next one peace
[Music]